tout le monde va
bien je ne vous entends pas c'est pas
grave on part tout de suite en direct
sur les
marches avec ah on retrouve leur enve
tout à l'heure me Glisson pas du tout
Laurent d'accord on retrouve Laurent
tout à l'heure très bien mesdemoiselles
bonsoir alors c'est votre premier
festival de canne et pour cause puisque
c'est votre la première fois que vous
tournez dans un film ça s'appelle bande
de filles c'est réalisé par Céline siama
en ouverture de la Quinzaine des
Réalisateurs c'est aussi votre première
télé donc j'ai envie d'avoir vos
premières impressions puisquon en est au
première fois
magnifique waouh impressionnant
franchement il il est beau Antoine en
vrai ouais ouais pas mal beau gosse oua
ou oua éidment et ouais on en vient à la
compétition officielle Laurent veille
vous étiez donc sur les marches les
autres il y a quelques instanture ex
passé euh pas grandchose Antoine il faut
bien le signaler peut-être à cause cause
de la grève il y avait il y avait assez
peu de monde ce soir ce sera pas les
marches de la Quinzaine il y avait quand
même la présentation en compétition du
nouveau film réalisé par le metteur en
scène anglais Mike Lee qui connaît bien
le Festival de Cannes il a notamment
obtenu a une palme d'or en 96 pour ce
cré mensonge il revient donc avec un
film en compétition l'histoire d'un
peintre très célèbre en Angleterre qui
s'appelle Turner peintre du 9e siècle le
film bien sûr est un biopic pour le coup
autant Grâce de Monaco on l'URA compris
éit pas un biopic celui-là est un vrai
biopic où on suit donc la carrière de ce
monsieur Turner le seul petit bémol
c'est que cet homme peintre de son état
a pas une vie passionnante donc le film
est magnifique mais vous l'urez compris
il est pas passionnant nous avons donc
maintenant le plaisir d'accueillir sur
le tapis
rouge l'équipe de Mister Turner
emmené par
[Musique]
réalisateur il est
accompagné question pour une
Campion je Campion bonsoir première
question quel légume a ouvert le
festival de Cann hier
soir un
avé quel est le somnifè le plus utilisé
sur la
Croisette Grâce de Monaco oui qui a fait
une sortie de route dans Grâce de
Monaco Olivier d' qui a bu plus Gérard
pardu bravo qu à la
suite est vraiment pointu en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cinéma
W ça va pierre vous êtes bieninstaller
là écoute rentrer avec du rap comme ça
et deux filles comme ça c'est tous les
jours Antoine c'est quand tu veux et
bien tous les soirs pourquoi pas plisir
très bien Zoé c'est un fan ému qui vous
parle parce que voilà je dois le
confesser j'aime beaucoup les femm bleu
oui bah oui j'a j'aime beaucoup les
femmes bleues et je peux pas beaucoup et
pardon non je suis aussi un fan de vous
mais j'aime bien les femmes bleues voilà
c'est ça remonte à loin je vous
expliquerai ça tout à l'heure aprs
l'émission c'est un peu privé et je
voudrais savoir évidemment s'il va y
avoir un avatar 2 un avatar d'Avatar
oui je crois que Jim a tellement adoré
la réaction de ses fans partout dans le
monde que les parties 2 3 et 4 sont
prévu Pandora on va y passer pas mal de
temps je crois que je vais faire la
promo d'Avatar jusqu'à l'âge de 50 ans
une nouvelle cinéma qui concerne notre
invité Zoé Saldana puisque James Cameron
a annoncé une suite à Avatar des types
en bleu qui vivent sur une autre planète
et qui ne parle pas notre langue
manifestement un film sur l'équipe de
France le point cagol et seamart
présenté par l'huile solaire belle au
soleil et il y avait du beau monde sur
le tapis rouge avec Kara maestroyani
Jeane Balibar la top mod Carly clos
audre totou Richard Anconina et
Géraldine pas et on a trouvé le
photographe le plus viv du festival il
est
là une dame belle de face et très serrée
deeds wou il y avait aussi pierre lescur
et la ministre de la Culture en léopard
cela fait plus de 500 ans que les
Léopards griment dans cet arbre et tiens
aliceagion a trouvé une petite
pièce W 1
€ ça j'aime bien des paillettes toujours
élégant un petit blazer c'est comme moi
oui il est bien je je vous l'ai dit vous
allez pas à can cette année vous le
savez nous l'avez pas
dit sinon j'aurais pas sorti une de mes
affaires jusqu'au bout il nous donnera
rien pourquoi est Méch par qu'ils sont
méchants dans cette boî soit ils ont
cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi
forg yours for si girl Let Me
Your
like do it right
[Musique]
now come on come on little
on
[Musique]